[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Daniel is
in Raleigh welcome to the show Daniel
how are you
doing hey thank you guys so much for
having me I'm I'm a big fan we
appreciate that what's your question
today of course so I'm 18 I'm a freshman
at UNCC and I'm studying Business and
Entrepreneurship cool um I own my own
business and I've been having
difficulties being able to do a good job
both running my business and also doing
a good job in school what's your
business we are an event entertainment
company we specialize in balloon animals
and face paint cool are we talking like
kids birthday parties carnivals like
what are your main gigs we do some kids
birthday parties we do lots of festivals
restaurant work um we work with some of
the sports teams in North Carolina like
the Panthers and the Hornets cool um
yeah all right and how successful has
this business been and how much time are
you putting into it it's it's been
pretty successful I started it when I
was 12 and for five years I was
practicing and getting to be the best
balloon twister I could um and I've
hired up a team to help me run this
while I'm in college um last year in
2022 we only made $2,200 but this past
year we were able to make over 25,000
great and that's net profit yes yes
wonderful and you're saying hey this is
a lot for me to run while I'm in college
yes sir yes okay and how how many
classes are you taking like how many
hours are you devoting to school and how
much free time do you have right now I'm
devoting about probably 30 to 40 hours
to school um and another 30 hours to my
business um and it's just kind of a lot
while I'm also trying to be social and
have a good time in college um so so the
question I have is is this a long-term
business play for you or is this
something you kind of started it's
throwing off the cash and you kind of
enjoy it I mean what's the strategy here
with this business as it is
today I I I'm enamored with what I do I
I love making balloons for a living it's
a lot of fun I want to do it for life um
this is a business I want to own and
grow to hopefully be a national change
someday um and we've been growing really
well this year and last year and this is
what I want to do with my life um and
I'm going to school for a chance to
learn how to better grow my business
while also getting to have fun while
getting an education well so you've got
you mentioned three things you've got
school youve got the business and you
got a social life it doesn't sound like
you can do all three of those to the
level that you want so you got to start
going okay let me reverse engineer this
what's most important longterm and
that's going to determine what's most
important in the short term and I I'm
not trying to be koi with the answer but
it's like okay maybe I don't take as
many classes I can still pursue the
degree I'm not in any way telling you to
drop out of college but I'm saying
something's got to give or you do less
gigs with the business yeah that's the
other or you're less involved that's
right the business stays where it is for
now meaning it doesn't grow until you
have more time to give to it something
has to give way
here that's true can you delegate more
to the team I can um I've hired up a
manager that will start I'm training him
in sales right now and that's a big
thing I've been dealing with is sales
for the business and taking the sales
calls and hopefully I'll have more time
to focus on other things whether that's
higher leverage opportunity for our
business or more time towards school I'm
not sure yet what is the thing that
you're most valuable in in the business
right now you just mentioned one aspect
you've been doing sales what's the thing
that only you can do right
now right now it's sales um but
hopefully soon it won't
be um I'd say I have a lot of the
strategy for the business I'm the one
that makes the instructional videos on
how to learn balloon twisting since we
train our own balloon twisters
um so just I guess HR and growing the
team as well as finding the customers
and making the right decisions to get
customer
leads okay and who's paying for school
right now right now my parents are um
they're paying for the first year or two
um and I will be able I I won't have
issues paying for school afterwards
either so you have no debt and you have
a pile of money in the bank and you're
also putting money away that you're
making from the business yes sir I save
almost all of my income incredible
because that's an important piece of
this equation is not going into debt I
want to see you finish school if that's
a goal for you to get this degree that
will help you flourish in business and
it sounds like you want to do this
long-term full-time as soon as you're
out of school yeah so this is a
temporary you got what three more years
or you in the first year I'm I'm in my
first year I'm I'm a freshman yes so the
other question is how do we expedite
College can you take on more credits and
just Crush through this so you're 21
years old graduating to pursue this
business that's true might mean you slow
down in order to speed up and so that
might mean delegating it might mean the
business just doesn't go for a season
and that you got to be okay with that
because you're doing a lot at once right
now and I don't want to see your gr
suffer while the business suffers and
you end up not making progress on
either that's that's true that's that's
a good point I I appreciate it yeah um
so I'd sit down with the with the folks
that you have see what kind of hires you
need to make while making this business
sustainable because you don't want to
eat into all the profits trying to just
keep this business afloat to where it's
not really accomplishing anything for
you yes sir so that's that's some big
decisions to make at your age I'm proud
of you man you've done really well thank
you I I really appreciate it thank you
best of luck with the future anything
else we can help with yeah um so I've
been following you guys' baby steps and
I'm now on baby step five and I mean I'm
18 years old I don't have a wife or kids
and I don't even have a girlfriend so it
feels a little premature to start saving
for my child's college fund uh what
would you recommend doing once I make it
to baby step five and I'm not sure how
to move forward I would focus on a
homeown payment fund and that might just
be a general high yield savings account
and you put every extra dollar you can
into that high yield savings account and
it's sitting there making you four to 5%
uh the other thing you could do is open
up a Roth IRA and contribute to that and
Max went out for the year based on your
stage and based on the fact that you
told me you're going to graduate debt
free so I think both of those are wise
for your future goals cuz when you
graduate adulthood is going to hit you
like a ton of bricks with bills and
you're going to want to do stuff and buy
a home one day and so to be ahead of the
game with no debt and a pile of money in
the bank dude you're going to be light
years ahead of your
peers that that's the plan thank you um
right now I have about half of my money
saved in a high yield savings account
and half of my money saved in the stock
market specifically with Vu and
RSP um how do I know how to allocate
money to reinvest in my business versus
allocate money for the stock market how
do I know where I should be investing
more of my money well I would look at
you know what the last year of business
expenses has looked for you what's
coming up in the next year for you know
hiring and we got to upgrade our
equipment and so that's the amount of
money I'd be starting kind of a syncing
fund and reserves for but outside of
that you've got the money set aside in
your savings account and so if worse
came to worse you could kind of Rob
Peter to pay Paul in a sense to cover
any business expense but if you're
running this thing debt-free and you've
got some money to cover those equipment
expenses rentals whatever your needs are
you're in great shape as far as the
business and so unless it's making a new
hire which hopefully they're going to
produce enough Revenue to offset what
they cost you so that's going to be the
goal running this business I'm going to
send you a copy of Dave's book entree
leadership as well Daniel that's our
playbook for how Dave built this thing
from a card table in his living room to
the ramsy Empire with over a thousand
team members in this amazing campus and
I think it will encourage you along the
way as you're actually hiring people at
18 years old I mean what an impressive
kid this is this is an adult and his
parents did a great job raising him well
he's asking the right questions yeah I
mean certainly at 18 looking long term
like this and having to make make these
kind of tough decisions very
entrepreneurial you love seeing that in
this generation and um really
interesting to see and you know I I
never want to push anybody to drop out
of college but at some point how much
what business training do you need
versus a true four-year degree maybe
even looking at more business classes
business training small business things
like that that's what I'd be looking at
and Daniel if you ever come by Ramsey
Solutions I'd love you to twist me a
little camel balloon you think that'd be
fun what do you think Ken I yeah I would
actually love to see that create your
free every dooll budget today the
simplest way to budget for your life